[Music]
recently christian and i directed our
first movie first feature film and uh it
was a little intimidating talking to
some of the very talented actors we
convinced to do the film one of whom was
patrick duffy patrick is an actor that
christian and i watched while we were
growing up step by step day by day
um
we loved patrick duffy and uh
on that show and
when he came to set he was could not
have been nicer uh very cool for us and
i asked him kind of gingerly because i
didn't want to be condescending or
disrespectful in any way and i said the
movie took place in savannah georgia so
i said patrick are you comfortable we'd
love for it to have just a touch of a
southern accent is that something that
you're okay with are you comfortable
doing that and he stared at me
as neutral as he could be he was like um
yes well i i was on a show called dallas
for 16 years
so yeah yeah i'm comfortable fairly
comfortable
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long and life could be
a dream sweetheart
[Music]
with me as always is definitely now
always
my quarantine quarantined
buddy
my quarantine mate
uh christian hi
uh feeling better
what stop bringing up my health well
people are now aware of it um i'm
feeling a little you may be clearing
your throat a few times that's the last
lingering vestige of this yeah it's it's
stuck in my chest a little bit but
that's uh the last symptom i have no
other covid symptoms now i don't bring
it up again well but i hate talking
about it because now the more i talk
about it the more i realize how
fortunate
i am i know to have had the version of
it that i've had of course and that's
why it was really embarrassing that it
was at all in the news because it was
taking up
space and
people's attention from
far more
you know there are people who are
obviously are dying from it
and
people who are
really really suffering from it yeah i
was not neither of us were those yeah
thankfully thankfully i mean it wasn't
pleasant
right but it but it certainly wasn't um
it wasn't the level of of where it is
yeah that's that for a lot of people i
won't bring it up again but if i clear
my throat no yeah that's what it is like
that
it's because i have some garbage in my
chest okay and garbage of course is if
you're from massachusetts you know that
that means garbage yes um
so
duffy patrick duffy as soon as i said
that to him i felt i felt idiotic of
course um
and he was very nice about he
that guy could not he was such a
gentleman
what a sweetheart of a man um patrick
was uh
was very patient and he was definitely
patient about that about um me not
realizing that he could do a southern
accent so patrick he wasn't insulted not
at all
even though he easily could have been
yeah he's on this show for 68 years it's
not just not just on the show but
uh one of the leads in the show
like an iconic show yeah it was a very
famous show i remember our mother was
really into that show um and patrick
himself she used to like we would watch
step by step as we mentioned we watched
an episode of step by step last night
and god i hadn't seen that show since i
was a kid and
it's it's he's so handsome and good in
it i just remember thinking funny but
when we watched it as kids remember
thinking oh he's like an old guy and
last night
he's a dad he's like an older dad and
last night i was watching it like he's
like my age yeah he's a young guy young
handsome guy young handsome yeah um why
are we talking about patrick duffy well
i'll tell you why because our guest
today was like many of you maybe or your
parents or your grandparents was a huge
fan of dallas
the tv show not i don't know about this
maybe maybe yeah in fact i think he did
mention the city i think he does like
the city uh he worked he did mention the
city he worked on it
kid show that anyway we'll get to that
but yeah both a fan of not a huge fan of
the city but um a bigger fan of the show
our guest today you you know him of
course because uh you know him to be a
big fan of dallas mo raka mo is um
a humorist uh
what else it's hard to describe he is a
humorist
that's the most general umbrella that i
think he would fall on yeah he he
became famous on the daily show as a
correspondent years ago uh jon stewart
since then he has he has become a
commentator on cbs sunday morning he
does human interest stories
every it's every week right yeah it's
every sunday it's uh cbs sunday morning
and that was always the job that that
was like a dream job for me it was uh
one that charles kuralt for years had he
would basically go around and
do human interest stories throughout the
country he would go from
usually in smaller towns and
it was just something i always like
fantasized about i thought it would be
such a cool job to have and mo
does that now he's he he's filling
charles kuralt's legendary shoes and
filling them so well uh filling them out
he's wearing new shoes um and he has a
podcast that you like that i haven't
heard yet but i would it is i'd like to
listen to it it's called obituaries and
i also am halfway through his book
mobituaries the podcast is based on the
book and there's a lot of stuff
uh in the book that's not in the podcast
and vice versa so i would recommend both
of them um it's basically about he looks
at certain
forgotten or maybe overlooked historical
figures
and he gives them a proper obituary it's
it's just the the best and ideal it is
it's so good and um he puts his uh very
humorous spin on things but it's also
more than that it's just so informative
and uh it's it's such a fun
read for the book and it's such a fun
podcast listen and had you met him
before you did this yeah we met him tom
a couple months earlier remember yeah
but had you met him before that that was
a brief interaction yeah i'm trying to
remember where i know he was friends
with my friend john hodgman with whom i
did the
mac pc commercials and so i think i met
him through john years ago i
i i i saw him
once at a like a screening for something
he was with scott rudin and so i was
very nervous scott ruins a big like
hollywood producer
could make or break a career and so i
was really like he never made you or
broke out oh no he's yet to
make or thankfully break my career um
but uh
mo is just somebody that i've always
admired and he's such a great intellect
and uh such a good humored person um
i've always really liked him so there
are a few subjects that i bring up and
so i just want to give a really brief
some context really quick uh one of the
episodes one of them obituary's episodes
is about thomas paine one of the
founding fathers uh um an often
forgotten founding father and it's ties
into a place that we can talk about this
afterwards right yeah okay because you
you also contextualize it in the
interview i knew what thomas paine was
and how the only six people came to his
funeral he was the founding father oh
good all right you did all that i did
okay you didn't mind it's totally
unnecessary i bring up chang yeah and
you talk about their sex life
one is ten kids one of the eleven kids
okay they took turns i did it doesn't
explain the whole thing i shouldn't be
doing this totally should not okay sorry
here we go so uh without further
ado
don't you hate saying that i do so
whenever i do say it i do i do whatever
i do say it i really lean into it i know
i do i like you make fun of it yeah what
other words you do that with um
i do that with something else i'm sure
there's other things i do
yeah i never just say without further
ado yeah i do
it's also because i don't speak french
yeah and i never studied french so i
feel like a poser when i okay
i pose you um so this
adieu
my conversation avec
the grand intellect
with mo raka coming up next
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again so we'll meet again
[Music]
i love your show so much it's such an
interesting it's i i hope this doesn't
sound insulting but it's
like a very interesting cliffs notes of
these people's lives and uh i'll take
that yeah and you also expose certain
things that i would never have um
considered about some of these lives but
but the thomas paine one is so
interesting because it
he's somebody that i'm aware of in
history vaguely and
you talked about this in the episode but
uh
the connection to something as tangible
as marie's crisis was
so
interesting and exciting to me
well i also it's because i i had
i never went to maurice crisis all that
much oh i have oh you have you've been a
lot a lot yeah i love it i love it yeah
it sounds like you've probably been more
than
than i have um
but i do i do like it a lot and
it's just so interesting to me that
there's this plaque outside of it with
his face saying that he died on this
spot and
you know
hundreds of people line up there week
after week to get in how many people
have actually noticed the plaque i know
i know these
significant great men and women in
history are just so quickly forgotten
how
you know so fast yeah isn't it a little
bit liberating
to know that you'll be forgotten right
away yes it is
you know you have kids most people end
up having kids yeah
and so that extends your whether your
half-life whatever it extends it a
little bit longer yeah but can you name
your great-grandparents
no i can't right some and i've know and
i wonder if they
what they laughed at and what they you
know if what they thought about
something is something like farting or
what foods they like you know i've
always wondered
people must have had very bad breath
breath
didn't
were they self-conscious about it was it
even taboo to smell that bad uh can i
just talk about body odor for one second
no one
no one
is with me on this but it is my distinct
memory i'm 51
that everyone in the 70s had b.o that
people just had bo oh really
and you just sort of dealt with it i
wonder what that would be i thought that
people wore less yoda and when i brought
this up to people people defensively
that's not true in the 70s everybody was
already wearing deodorant yeah there
were all those ads like raise your hand
if you're sure and all this for for
different that was in the 70s or was
that 80 was was that it probably was in
80s as well but but i remember yeah so i
think i just wonder how people well also
people had a lot of out like mad men
period probably people have right
were everywhere yes i remember that
smells which clings to everything even
and my parents my dad was one of the he
was such a so anti-smoking that he would
make such a big deal about being in a
restaurant we would he was so
embarrassed a few times we would we'd go
every week to a restaurant called
luigi's and he would always say
you know just as far away from the
smoking section as possible but even
when you're in the non-smoking section
it i remember it drifting over uh
kids now they're growing up in such a
such a
more uh pleasant
smelling time i would say well or i mean
it's definitely right that are their
olfactory senses less stimulated i mean
i also yes because i can obviously it
wasn't that long ago that you could
smoke in a bar so when i lived in west
hollywood and i'd go down to a bar
called revolver and i'd come back my
clothes oh yeah smoke and it was oh and
that's where it was bar after par i mean
in that area of west hallway yes right
and it just it just so it's kind of nice
to not have your clothes smelling like
that yeah but then you think of that the
70s you have distinct memories of that
and that's a strong this sense memory is
um i wonder yeah what it smelled like
200 years earlier in this time uh
i i it's
that's one of the things i love about
the show you you bring to life some of
these elements of of people's lives and
and
that that chang and hang one where you
talk about
them having how did they have sex how
did they
uh the idea that one would be you know
when one would have three days with
their lover it's it's no it's such a
fascinating show yeah the well thank you
thanks no the the uh the um
the the reason i wanted to do an episode
on on chang the original
siamese twins was because um
the only thing i remembered
or knew about them and i think a lot of
people i don't know if you know this is
there was a picture of them it's sort of
the picture of them as grown men i think
they're weird they're sort of like an um
almost like in white tie they're they're
suited up yeah and they have their most
comfortable position changing because
they that the
band of flesh was only five and a half
inches that connected them but their
most comfortable position was side by
side with their arms around each other
like two friends yeah come coming home
from a night out drinking well it also
especially intrigued me because my i do
this show with my brother i feel very
connected to him and uh the idea of
being
permanently that connected is
really interesting um to have lived like
even the way he died you know uh
and you bring it to life in such a
is such a clear way it's it's um i
particularly love that episode i think
just because of how close i am to yeah
we wanted to we were trying to get the
property brothers to come in because we
i had visited their um their home
in north carolina where they ended up
settling and uh
and how it it
one of the homes had been built i think
the house i visited i visited two of
them but the first one was the one that
they lived in together with their wives
it was kind of complicated they married
sisters but the the doors were extra
wide for them to get through there was a
chair built for two people like an easy
chair right the eight sisters right
right exactly and um
um and so i i kind of thought it would
be fun to talk to oh that would brothers
about if they had had to if they were
conjoined if they
would have built things yeah
it's so interesting so the houses still
stand so it's a couple of the houses so
they lived in one house together and
then they decided once they started
having children because i think chang
and
addie
sired 10 kids
she hired 10 kids with addie the other
side are 11.
yeah exactly 11 kids
um and then they got separate houses and
and one of those separate houses exists
i'm not sure if the other one does it's
amazing you talk about the uh the kind
of meditative state that one of them
would go into when the other one was
with their why you know was intimate
um
and and just the fact that human a human
being would be capable of going into
such a state uh
yeah i guess it's funny i mean i i
wonder if people understand it now more
that
now that people are really into
meditation i mean i've only tried
meditating i did a story on it for cbs
sunday morning that's honestly the only
time i tried it i don't didn't have the
discipline to keep with it but uh um but
yeah this author i talked to yunte huang
who wrote about them um
said you know the two questions
everybody has is how do they die and how
do they have sex with their wives
everyone does the two things people want
to know yeah sex and death and uh and
that he called us called it alternate
mastery that um
they'd go to one brother's house for
three days and when when they were there
at the house of say aang and sarah then
chang obviously had to be there as well
and he would just go into like a
computer sleep state
and shutting down yeah sort of shutting
yeah yeah not turning off but yeah going
into this
i i imagine like a kind of a very soft
hum coming from him
or or whatever the sounds were would
just be muted a little bit right right
and then they'd go to the other house
and the other brother would do the same
thing and it's unbelievable it is kind
of beautiful when you think of that it
is yeah that's interesting that people
would ask about those two things sex and
i guess those are the two things that
are relatable yes sir maybe it's just
that
those are the essential things on
people's minds that's all constantly
taking up some of our bandwidth yeah
yeah lots of sex and
fear of death right yeah it's fun and
that these historical greats can be not
reduced to that but
can be explained that way through those
two things um yeah in the context of
chang and eng i'm thinking about all the
kids they have that legacy that that
continues to thrive in north carolina
with that family the bunkers i think
that they were uh that isn't a great
name that their names are great i know
so ironic yeah well i think that part of
what what drew me to that story of chang
and was because there were two stories
there was a story
of these two brothers who come to
america basically as indentured servants
yeah they become 17 right and become two
of the first celebrities in america and
all this yeah and but then their
descendants
um
have gone through this process
that i think a lot of people can relate
to where
you know
we're all sort of embarrassed at points
you know about our family or parts of it
like little moments
even in simple ways like if you you're
embarrassed when you're when you're you
know at a vulnerable age and your
parents pick you up at school or
something and you want to i don't know
right like a little thing sure oh i
can't right yeah right preaching the
choir right right
choir yeah and they were and their
descendants became very
embarrassed through the years about
being descended because everybody i
think thought like ooh how did your
forefathers have sex and reproduce
that's right they never talked about it
really and they were asian in north
carolina
which i found incredible exactly they
were slave owners and also that and that
now i'm not sure that accounted for
their embarrassment right the
descendants maybe some right but um
that definitely drew me to the story too
because they're not
they're really complicated they have
really complicated lives um
it's it's i was anticipating being on
your show and they asked me what
historical things would you like to talk
about two things that that i've always
been interested in one was samuel mudd
the man who set
the leg of john walks booth and then was
sent to a prison in the dry tortugas uh
south of key west there was that story
that i found really interesting but also
james garfield the presidency of james
garfield especially you know you think
about it in today's context he was such
a
qualified person to be president he
could have been such a great president
even even in his
six months that he was president uh
he did some very meaningful things and
the way he died too to be assassinated
that way and then for the the surgeons
at the time to
work on his wound is his abdomen without
uh yeah without sanitizing their hands
something we were just talking about
just now you walked in the studio and
you
gave me an elbow bump uh because of the
i don't know why really i just found it
weird like what is he doing why is this
guy why is this guy pretending to be a
chicken right
there was some power move
some tests well to see if i would go
along with it um so i've been to the
prison that samuel mudd was in no kid
kidding kind of amazing you have really
there
jefferson yeah yeah exactly exactly
it's um fort jefferson it is i think the
second to the last i oh it's been a
while but basically i used to always
think that key west was the the furthest
but then there's the the dry tortugas
yeah the dry tortugas and there's
another one in the middle
of an m i think but anyway it's the
second to the very last one i think of
all the keys
and it's
it is it was at one point the largest
piece of masonry in the western
hemisphere it was it was so huge
but yeah so i've been in that cell
really it's really well he was there for
how many a long time i don't remember
how long he was there but you could find
the piece on youtube it's really
interesting it's really cool together
people go there and they scuba dive and
yes it's a big
snorkling yeah
[Music]
just inhaling too deeply right and
snorkeling it doesn't require any tanks
or anything to you it doesn't i just i
don't i'm not very good at it i can't
keep the thing straight or i don't i
don't really anyway i just need to work
on it i guess do you enjoy outdoor
things do you enjoy
yeah
i mean
do i
i've only maybe i should do more i need
to take more time off and become an
outdoorsy person before
before it's too late but for cbs sunday
morning do you often do assignments like
that where you you you travel a lot for
it well i did go scuba diving
or was it snorkeling in in mexico
because there was an underwater
sculpture garden thing that i went to
that was kind of cool near cancun
uh i was in a hustle competition i
hustled the dance
well that's not outdoorsy but right
physical it's physical no i i love
gymnastics and anyway so yeah what do
you so you travel for most episodes
yeah we do i do for cbs sunday morning i
do about 20 features a year wow yeah do
you enjoy that going around i love it i
love it it's like going back to college
and taking only electives it really is
oh yeah it's nice being on a show that's
not so dependent on the hard news cycle
right we address stuff that's going on
that people you know we address politics
but
that's the human intelligence don't love
it yeah they they they have mixed
feelings about it they don't want us to
ignore it completely although some do i
think i do stories on a whole range of
things right now i'm about to do i'm
working on a story i was just on a plane
reading a biography of peggy lee because
this is what it is it's the 100th
birthday that's right you mentioned that
on one of the shows i think oh did i
really yeah i think on um oh you know
you mentioned on the lawrence welcome
yes yes friends because we went on a big
north dakota riff and lo and
somebody came to me and they said peggy
lee's daughter
is wants to cooperate into a piece and
her mother apparently had this
extraordinary archive of people
through the years and she was also a
songwriter but that spanned all these
musical generations that i i think don't
hold me to this but i think like you
know paul mccartney would come over and
she would record you know
them singing
or something so i'm really excited to
dive into this yeah i forgive my
ignorance did she die young peggy leeway
she didn't die that young um i she did
peggy lee die about 20 years ago i think
yeah and um oh okay yeah so she was she
lived to be an older yeah she yeah i
mean i think she lived close to 80 i'm
not i'm not sure but uh but she was from
this tiny town in north dakota north
dakota you mentioned some other people
from north dakota with khalifa i think
dakota yeah and angie dickinson
big bad mama
right yes big bad mamas
i remember leonard malton's movie book
was very important to me he had a book
of uh movie critiques and and i was so
um
i i just reading the word nudity in a
description about was was uh kind of
titillating for me at the time i
remember uh and big bad mom i think had
i think the word nudity how old were you
uh 29
no um i was i was a kid i was so it was
1980 so i was 10 i think so were your
parents pretty strict about what you
uh
and so yeah but i wouldn't say
we couldn't watch our rated movies we
couldn't um they sh
but at the time we didn't have cable or
anything it was pretty you know without
the internet it was i don't think kids
understand now how easy it was to
shelter your kids from stuff like that i
think you're right but i kind of in
retrospect sort of liked having a strict
upbringing i kind of how so well i don't
know it kind of maybe made things even
more tantalizing oh yeah i mean my
parents have such control over my tv
diet oh really they tried to exercise
and it kind of made it more exciting to
try to evade those restrictions to like
sort of like to get through and watch
things that i wasn't supposed to watch
and what would be considered off limits
then
anything you know when sitcoms portrayed
what my parents thought was sort of
immoral behavior oh wow right like out
of wedlock sack something like that
put it like that now right
now i know but i don't know yeah so my
father set up this
i mean it was really kooky when i think
about it
um this sort of
that i could watch one hour of
inappropriate tv a week
i think you may only murder one person
like a pervert bank
yeah yeah
and my friend fate sailing called it a
tv rum spring up
and so
at first it was dallas i was like that's
not even a question of dallas but then
when dallas started to kind of jump the
shark then i switched over to dynasty
but that was something i was like i have
to watch dynasty that's the alley i know
you were into charlie's angels yeah but
charlie's angels had already sort of
passed it i don't
think
we were
um i don't i'm pretty sure that we were
not allowed to watch charlie's angels
yeah that would have been but but the
thing is that the angels didn't have
like salacious private lives uh-huh they
just did that
right and that didn't interest you
it didn't really interest well it
interested me like
like
gay kids love charlie's angels for a
whole separate reason right so like that
was that's a whole different so they
loved it but it was like but more like
oh my god it's so exciting yeah
yeah
like right that's my strength yeah yeah
pretty good um
i was just my my friend the same one
with misophonia she has a 14 month old
daughter and um and she was she picks up
little words from from uh shows that she
watches and stuff and she was from big
bird she got a word from big bird out of
sight or something like that it was some
very
kitschy sounding delivery it was a very
and we were talking about uh
characters in pop culture who we
who now would be considered
gay i suppose but at the time but there
they weren't allowed to say that really
there wasn't allowed like like herme in
rudolph the red-nosed reindeer who just
wanted to be a dentist but you know when
you consider
how hermes sounded and the things he was
saying and how he felt out of place um
so there is a oh gosh talk about bad
memory and i wanna and i'll remember it
in a few moments but there is a term
for
these characters the the zanies oh so my
friend eric near who's so smart was we
were talking about great memory yeah who
was talking about like charles nelson
riley yes paul rip taylor paulin paulin
and the these were known collect these
were known by a lot of people as the
zanies and so it was
done a little bit with a wink because
the public at that time
most people didn't really
most people didn't know openly gay
people so people like paul lind and
charles nelson riley would be put into
these roles that you know they would be
playing husbands and fathers but it was
always kind of in a heightened
yeah
yeah exactly
and and
and some people said this is very
you know
maybe not pc
or some people might be bothered by this
but in a way
they wouldn't really be able to play
those roles now
because they'd be known as gay right
yeah and it would be it would be a
little trickier right it brings up a
whole host of other issues but in a way
i'm not i'm not arguing to go back to
the time yeah
the good old days really clear the good
old times oh god
right but it was kind of a kind of a
weird moment because yeah those roles
wouldn't really exist today and they
wouldn't be cast that way sir and they
certainly wouldn't be yeah of course
they wouldn't have fam i mean they would
have they would have families in a much
different way and much
not as quote unquote conventional um
and jim j bullock i'm now i'm thinking
of a whole host of yeah yeah yeah i'm
sure gay people are watching those shows
were like
but if they turned to their straight
brother or sister and said oh that guy's
probably homosexual they'd probably say
what are you talking about oh right they
wouldn't get that you know he's just
funny he's just he's zany yeah that's
interesting well i remember rip taylor
who also i think recently passed away
his thing and and it's interesting to
reduce people to
this and i'm sorry to do that which is
again one of the things i love about
your show you you took a figure like um
jimmy carter's uh billy billy cart jimmy
carter's brother and you humanized him
in a way that i i i certainly i think a
lot of people would be surprised by and
and it's it's it's also very respectful
what you do um but i was just about to
say about rip taylor he's the guy that
threw confetti right you know it's
amazing to to have and he was a popular
figure in entertainment um well it's
it's that that is more maybe
same sort of the same thing and maybe
more towards the um liberace end of the
spectrum yeah right like like like i
suspect that with somebody as flamboyant
as rip taylor and liberace more people
got it and so more people were like oh
that guy's gay they probably would have
used the word homosexual back then right
yeah but um
and and the joke even then probably was
that only elderly ladies
were you know were doting on them as if
they were potential husbands to their
daughters right like they they were the
only ones who didn't get it yeah yeah
yeah yeah maybe most people didn't get
it maybe who knows it depends when
and again i i it's interesting to
examine some of these historical figures
in that context today we know a lot more
about much more liberal time i'm
thinking about thomas paine because i
just heard the episode
what made him so abhorrent to so many
people you know i i was fascinated by
that and you you you are it seemed to be
as well uh i i'm interested in in well
in the case of thomas paine you know who
wrote common sense who gave the
intellectual
justification for the diet christ
right
crisis and did all these amazing things
but only six people showed up to his
funeral and amazing
is you know part of it is that he had a
really difficult personality and isn't
it i mean that's something i feel like
everybody can relate to sure
people who are difficult to get along
with um have a steeper hill to climb i
mean you don't want to i mean on shows
i've been on i remember
i'm remembering when i um when i was on
the daily show when jon stewart was the
host and
there was a correspondent who was being
tried out and i'll never forget this
early on i'm not going to name her
because she's um oh it's a woman yeah
yeah it's a woman who had been who had
been taken out to do a field shoot i was
very new at the show
and the producer came back into the
office
um having just worked with this
perspective correspondent doing a piece
and the boss the big boss walked in and
said to this producer how was she
and the producer who was a woman said
you know she was kind of a pain in the
ass like she spent a lot of time
worrying about her makeup i just didn't
you know she was paying the ass and the
boss said fine we won't use her again
wow and i once i'm telling you it made
an impact on me oh my god because and i
was young i'd never been on tv never
wore makeup again
because i was like i pulled off those
false eyelashes and i said i'm done i'm
going oh natural i'm going to be brave
yeah and and you to this day well no i'm
wearing a still a little blush
but i'll never forget that i thought wow
if somebody had said that about me just
be easy to take it's so important to be
easy to take now i'm not saying that
part of thomas paine being a pain in the
ass yeah
brought us to breaking from the crown
because he was he was um uncompromising
and that's important i'm not downplaying
that but it is also interesting the role
i think that personality
interaction plays and you give both
their due credit i think um the first
being the the former being that i i
didn't realize that the states all
thought of themselves as so independent
right that there was no he was the first
to kind of galvanize all those states
and and describe uh and almost
create an american narrative though
right like he rebranded the word
american yeah before that before the
revolution american um was
basically defined as cracker hillbilly
yeah and
and and marylanders were marylanders
virginians were virginians and you know
they were all resentful of the crown but
thomas paine said well good let's all
get together as one nation we're not
going to be 13 different nations when we
break we're going to be one and we'll be
americans and he rebranded the word it's
really brilliant
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello
[Music]
uh you mentioned being catholic you went
to a prep school at georgetown to
georgetown
um
what kind of student were you that you
must have been a good student to i was a
good student yeah i was
i wasn't
i was a good student i mean things were
ranked a lot i loved and i was okay with
that
my um
junior year latin teacher was a jesuit
named father john jay nicola who if you
watch the movie the exorcist at the end
of the movie he's the chief consultant
or you know no kidding
and so when we would do he was an
exorcist and so when we would
do well in latin all get above a certain
on a pop quiz get a above a certain
score then he would tell us exorcism
stories oh wow i never doubted and uh it
went there i just said it was kind of
thrilling about the making of the movie
he was he was great and uh
um
did you wow
how many he must have had how many could
he have he he i don't i could wow
i can't recycle i wonder
um
i didn't even i didn't realize they shot
that there of course in in the dc area
yeah
oh the exorcist stairs oh right where
where jason miller is right um falls
down the steps at the end after he
says after he is strangling reagan and
and i forget the line now but basically
the devil possesses him right but he has
enough strength still the good in him to
throw
the window down the stairs and my two
older brothers ran up and down those
steps but i was too scared to do it i
mean that was oh yeah i've walked up
them subsequently
but on mustard and courage i mustered
the courage
yes yes
but um but um
so what we asked well as a student but
so you were you were the young and uh so
i was
um it was an all-boys school yes i was
nervous to go
i come from public school
and i was nervous to go but i had a
brother that was two years that is two
years older than me
and
was more of a jock and so i basically
had diplomatic immunity like i would
have been
i'm not saying i would have been dead
meat because it's a good school yeah i
would have but i would not have been
given a chance i think if i didn't have
an older brother who was threatening to
kick the ass of anyone who picked on oh
really dead oh so i did
so i could go around singing show tunes
and like and doing my thing
because if anyone touched me hello my
baby hello mohan yeah yeah
sorry
but well mo rock is also a tough name
morocca yeah it's a tough sounding
if a kid named mo raka were coming to my
school from
the dc area i'd be i'd be intimidated
okay but i was um
five ten and weighed 110 pounds
i mean that's quite literally true so i
was wow and you know and at the time the
school
didn't have a robust musical theater
program
that's that's all i wanted to do so i
was not a natural fit
but um but i was not a natural fit at
all but i did but you must start in the
musical you must have i mean it was
probably good for you you did yeah and i
i would do the all the plays and the
musicals that were
that they did have you know which
weren't many but um it's funny i went to
a jesuit all boys jesuit high school as
well and um the the drama department was
this
one woman i won't
name her um but the all of the
the administrators all the other jesuits
kind of dismissed it uh like oh this is
just sort of um
they really concentrated on sports i
mean athletes yeah athletes totally who
were the important which jesse was
school he was fairfield prep in
connecticut it's a great school you know
well yeah no i mean all the jesuit
schools i think sort of yeah
yeah um so as a result similarly that
there was not much of a an acting
program there um
but but then
when you go to harvard do you continue
to do that do you continue
yeah i continued to do it and then then
so i started um there's um a
organization called the hastings pudding
around yeah i've been around for a long
time and honestly the reason i
auditioned at first was i um
i was a freshman and i walked by i was
walking down this street holy oak street
and i'd and there was this building
which was i didn't realize was the hasty
pudding theater but there was a little
poster that said if you want to go to
bermuda for spring break and
you know
that seemed really exciting to me yeah
and otherwise i would have gone home to
bethesda maryland for spring break
because my parents weren't gonna weren't
the types they weren't gonna give money
to send me to you know some fancy they
were spending already a lot of money
just put me through college and uh um so
that was kind of the
incentive i thought wow that would be
really exciting to be in a musical so
and i i think i had heard of it and then
i went and i auditioned and
and i got cast and then you got to go to
bermuda yeah i was in it for all four
years and what made it sort of famous
now celebrities are everywhere
means anything anymore but at least back
then and
i you know started harvard in 1987.
every year
newsweek
would put like the picture of the man
and woman of the year was kind of a big
deal the hasty pudding organization
basically it's a it's like a 160 year
old drag show
it was until recently all men it just
changed
but and it was it's an originally
written musical and it's kind of a big
deal for a colleague it's all original
and students run it and they hire
professionals to come and interact and
choreograph but it's kind of a big deal
in this old theater it runs for 30 days
in cambridge and then it goes to new
york and then to bermuda for spring
break um and every year there's a man
and woman of the year that comes right
so when i was a freshman it was lucille
ball and steve martin and i always
remember
and this was so interesting to me it was
like
um
steve martin came he had just done
roxanne wow and he was upset that he
well maybe he wasn't really upset but he
hadn't been nominated for an oscar that
was kind of a big deal that year
everybody thought 1987 yeah 1987
yeah
1980 right into 1988 right so i guess
the movie was 1987. they announced the
oscar nominations right before he was he
came to be our man of the year
and he dropped an f-bomb which trust was
like
he was saying like he's like i got
[ __ ] by the academy but then i
remember he said the reason i accepted
your invitation
is because to be honored alongside
lucille ball
was to me just like the pinnacle yeah
and to my 19 then 19 year old brain
i thought
oh that that meant something to me the
idea that talent respects talent
regardless of generation because then as
a teenager i thought like steve martin's
cool
lucille balls for old yes yeah he's
going to think like oh who's that all
back
but
but he was in so it was so cool to see
someone as red hot
as steve martin
basically bowing down
to lucille ball and that
and i loved that i and i i hadn't you
know what i mean like yeah yeah talent
respects other talents yeah well it
wasn't just about their status as as
famous people and right which which now
today we know could mean anything could
mean uh you don't need any talent to
really have that kind of status uh
that's interesting yeah i remember at
the time
i remember that always struck me on the
muppets when there was um
[Music]
that's when you would see celebrity
interact with with the muppets i always
thought that the that they paid
deference to
mark hamill and to christopher plummer
all sort of equally and they all seemed
like they were excited to be there with
these muppets totally yeah god it's so
to me it's insane that sammy davis jr
was never on the muppets oh was he not i
i haven't heard that episode yeah you
did an episode about samuel i said
junior and it just like
huh i just seem strange with sammy davis
jr
i sammy davis jr was sort of the muppet
version of himself yeah like
yes
oh my god yeah he was he was right yeah
he was he had multiple elements yeah
crazily talented yes he had a muppet
energy to him too uh that's funny that's
interesting peter moreno was great on
the muppet show oh i don't you have to
see that because when you were talking
about sesame street earlier i was
thinking like i never liked sesame
street i always thought it was too kind
of maybe pamby
to me electric company felt like oh
dangerous
i profiled rita moreno and i told her
that my first tv memory is her going hey
you guys that's how she would open
um electric company with morgan freeman
oh right sure became you know morgan
freeman yeah yeah but he was still old
he was always old for some reason
that would be an interesting book to put
out always old people that
steve martin to me is always only
because of his prematurely gray hair but
since i was a kid he was uh
well wilfred brimley and i will try
the cheap wilford brown reference but
wilfred brimley i was watching him in
the china syndrome the other day and
he's already old but he's like in his
30s well when he was in cocoon i think
he may have been your age and he's
playing i'm already older yes
yeah i know wilford brimley is a perfect
example i've never seen him young
how long after
harvard
did you then
start the working at the daily show
you've had such an eclectic you had such
an eclectic journey up into that point
because you were in musical theater you
you did do after i did musical theater
so i went
i i didn't know what to
i i went to japan to study kabuki but
that's a funny sentence to say casually
of course you did i went to japan to
study kabuki
well
what happened was um there was a guy at
harvard younger a nice guy named steve
wardell and he said to me
you should go to japan it would be real
you could teach english and it would be
really interesting and he was a
undergrad who was writing a column for
an english language newspaper in japan
he was writing it from like dispatches
from harvard something like that
my father was a big japanophile and he
had spent time in japan so maybe that
was but truly i didn't really have that
much interest in japan it was one of
those things where i went
this is an interesting thing to do
that i won't be able to do at another
point right which is i don't know if
that's a good enough reason oh i think
so it was sort of
so i went over to japan
and i was and i intended to kind of just
sort of like
not bum around but kind of see the
country and teach english to make my way
no uh grasp of the language no grass for
the language and my father had done
business with a with a very atypical
japanese woman a really interesting very
like strong-willed and she's still alive
and she's wonderful and she gave me an
apartment to stay in which was the big
deal because tokyo so expensive but when
i got there she said all right what are
you going to do here i said well i
thought i'd teach english and she said
no you're not and i said why and she
said because
people who teach english in japan she
said don't have a good reputation they
usually aren't credentialed and they're
taking japanese people for a ride
charging too much and i don't want you
doing that
and
i said what am i supposed to do like i
have to like eat or something and i mean
and and
that question
didn't make sense to her she said we'll
figure that out but she said what do you
want to do in life and at that point i
thought i wanted to be an actor yeah and
she said do you know about kabuki and i
did know a little bit because it had
come to the kennedy center a few times
when i was growing up in dc
and uh and
so she said you'll study kabuki and she
just basically said this is what you'll
do
and you know if i
if i had my act together more i would
have written about this while it was
still fresh in my mind
but kabuki is very um
dynastic they're basically i think five
families that control it it's very
hierarchical and so
she was friends with one of the actors a
man who recently passed away named
ichikawa dancido who was
a very big deal and uh and so i would go
to his
gakuya his dressing room every day and i
would sit and say is a position where
your kneecaps almost want to pop off
on the tatami mats
and to to apprentice with him meant
just watching him you know did you ever
see jiro james of sushi
right he's just the guy spinning he's
just watching yes the knife
so that was the idea so i would go
and i would just watch him
so it was it was i was in this really
privileged unique position it was also
incredibly boring i bet i was going to
say
and why was that i know this was you so
your father's colleague somebody your
father has done business with yeah but
why did you give her so much deference
that because i had no choice she was
giving me an apartment
right and i was over there in japan it
was a big deal it was it would have been
a big deal at that time for me to go i'm
going home right and just ditching
so i thought let's just play this by ear
and so i would go there every day how
long did you do that for um i was in
japan then it seemed like a long time it
was only about three months and then a
couple months into it
don chito-san the the actor
almost out of a sitcom or at least the
the the movie version of this the
touchstone picture says that still
exists version of this would be so dumb
but the reality was it was close to the
version they would do which is he spoke
some english
and he said you don't like being here do
you and i said well you know it's a
little much in you know the hours and he
said you know
he said you know i didn't want to become
an actor
i dreamed of becoming an airline pilot
but because of the family i'm in i have
no choice he told me so he said so i'll
tell your sponsor that you're coming
here every day but you go off and do
what you want
so then i went off and i and i uh um
i taught english i got little flyers
printed up saying advertising and put
them at the supermarket against her
wishes again yes wow and then i and then
she had me do one
thing that she had no idea how i was
making money so first she thought i was
broke and
so she gave me a job the strangest job
in addition to my secret english
teaching work that i was doing where i
watched the fresh prince dj jazzy jeff
video summertime yes some summertime
okay right this is in 1991 yeah right so
1991 so i think maybe it was fairly new
and she said i don't think that the
japanese subtitles on that she was
working with something are correct
and so she said i need you to listen to
it to the words and transcribe the words
perfectly in english because she said i
think they've it's been mistranslated
and then i'll give it back to the
japanese translator and i got paid some
inordinate amount of money for listening
and just stopping and starting every few
seconds and writing down the lyrics to
summertime funny
and then you still you must still
remember i just remember the video yeah
philadelphia right yeah so like i
remember that and so
it
graded my memory and then i took my
money and i went off on a basic and i
went off on a trip into china and i did
some interesting things and that was my
japanese adventure it's so funny you
mentioned touchstone pictures because
it's now i'm now reminded of maybe
because of that good morning vietnam
there's a good morning vietnam element
to what you did oh just teaching english
and i think that was a touchstone
touchstone pictures yeah touch don't
pick it up it's always that like
it's always
good
it's like three men and a baby and yeah
but yeah i feel good that the trailer
was always something like that
close-up of shoes feet walking and
panning up to like the liberated
stronger person yes
uh that's amazing
it's incredible that that um you were
doing that in a clandestine way you were
doing something so responsible like
teaching english
yeah i guess yeah i mean i i get what
she what mrs sakai was saying yeah
probably
like some sketchy types of going over
there and being like yeah yeah this is
english yeah
so you never got to actually do the
kabuki you never forgot to wear it they
never i never put on the kabuki that was
never going to happen i think that that
would who knows what would have happened
i think like studying kabuki met me just
sitting there pretending
for like years until all right until i
had to have my knees replaced yeah it's
very changing of you to just be able to
go into that meditation
had i known about that i would have
totally gone into it and then i came
back to washington dc and i got a job as
a roller skating waiter at a french
restaurant because washington's always
been
sort of
washington has never it will never be a
sexy city
certain cities have real sex appeal like
i've only been to mexico city once but
it has
it's overpopulated it's polluted and all
that but it has like a sexy vibe hong
kong has that too yeah washington will
never have that it will always be sort
of clunky
with um
uh with pleated khakis even if they're
not wearing them
and you know like blue oxfords and like
and and you know and women wearing
talbots and like businessmen yeah yeah
it was a swamp
yeah i did well there's that right the
climate is really lousy this roller
skating french restaurant was considered
washington really being like on the edge
yeah
it was
so i did that and and i earned the money
to move to new york so that i could
audition for music oh wow you must be a
pretty good roller skater i'm able to do
that on
surfing is hard enough yeah i'm okay i
did a piece with carrie butler when she
was in xanadu and we did it all on
roller skates
and i did and so i can roller skate
backwards like cautiously but i'm pretty
good with that you so you began doing
musicals you you actually yeah and then
i had i so i would go i would go get
backstage magazine
yeah and i'd circle the auditions and
i'd go and i'd wait in line and i had
some success i was um
i was in a bus and truck of the far of
the forest lend me a tenor and around
all over the country
uh then i was um in i was in paper mill
playhouse oh sure yeah in
uh good theater great theater yeah i did
the southeast asian tour the musical
greece so i went through asia do you
know back to asia to do that
um wow canceled in kuala lumpur so we
had to spend an extra week in singapore
oh my god and how did they take greece
what would did you do was there any
trend so the the biggest issue honestly
in with greece is there had to be a
little bit of a tweaking of the book and
i'm not sure that they had permission to
do it because um indonesia is an islamic
country
and and
my memory is failing me but i think in
the stage musical either rizzo is
pregnant out of wedlock or there's a
scare that she may be
and i think the idea that she might be i
think there's just a scare yeah and that
was verboten and so
and the thing they did that was
that was sketchy not good in um
in uh when we were in jakarta was they
put posters all over the city with
olivia newton john and john travolta and
the tickets were like the equivalent of
seventy dollars also for people to pay
this money thinking they were going to
show up and see olivia newton john and
john travolta was pretty lousy yeah
and who did you play i played duty and
the youngest of the greasers and i have
to tell you that i've never spoken about
this but you know i have to tell you
that it was very um
he sings that song a-a-a-a my minor
you know does magic changes my heart
arranges
and the um
the director
was
very critical of me
in a very personal way and he said the
song is about having sex
you know having sex the first time i'm
not even sure if that's true and he said
you need to sing it
as if
you know you need to sing it i think he
even like said like sing it from your
loins or something yeah i was like 24
years old i mean i wasn't like you know
i did you had loins yeah i hadn't just
come from like a convent yeah anyway but
like but he but he but he said you need
to sing
you need to communicate you're not doing
it you're not doing it like it's about
sex oh my goodness
it was embarrassing but it also played
to my martyr complex when in a way at
least that i don't know that i have one
but anyway but that he eventually took
the song away from me oh my god he gave
the song
to the actor playing roger who was a
great guy and i think might be in the
lion king right now he's a really good
guy because you weren't singing it with
enough sexual
energy and it was but it was but the
criticism was so
personal in front of the company so the
suggestion being you don't have this
yeah
like a eunuch or something like that and
so he was like you're not like you need
to and i'm like what do you want me to
do yeah jesus do you want me to do oh do
you want me to like i mean seriously i
mean
so i think not being able to sing
those magic changes like i had just had
sex or like well are you in the throes
of the climate
like i was like actually i think that's
what he wanted to happen which brings up
all the other issues
but um but that and my unability my
inability i mean i have a good luck that
we all have things that we're frustrated
by especially as we get older that it's
going to be hard to do um
and the other one is that i i was never
able to do um uh backhand spring
unassisted because i was really into
gymnastics oh
is in my mind my
that
i think there's a chance
because i once took a gymnastics class
at chelsea piers and there was a
teamster actually in it like who was
able to do a round off backhand spring
he was not your typical teamster trust
me i guess like it's like a porn star
version of a team
whatever that is but i mean this guy was
extraordinarily good looking in like
great shape i'm like i haven't seen you
on a film set ever sorry i'm not i'm not
trying to answer the other side
no no it's a big demographic for us
hello hello again you're blooming over
we'll meet again
[Music]
so how did you make the transition to
the daily show then from music so what
happened was um a friend of mine uh um a
woman named stephanie simpson who was
also
working as an actor auditioning we were
kind of eating a lot of escarole
remember
for 99 cents
yes girls are green no
yeah i think it was like kale before
kale
uh yeah s girls were really annoyed at
how hot kale became
it was like the 90s ko yeah these
escarole swiss chard is like when's our
day coming well stress chart is always
how many people think swiss chard is a
cheese
but like but like escarole my mom used
to make escrow all the time in italian
soup it's really uh it's a staple of an
italian soup i forget of um
yeah yeah uh you know so um she um it's
um uh
she went down to dallas for a weekend to
dallas texas to help
a client of her mother's but
with
a tv project a tv pitch
and she never came back but that's sort
of what ended up happening wow she went
down to work on an idea for children
show for pbs
and
um she ended up calling me
and uh and saying do you want to come
down
move come down to dallas to work on this
tv show the tv show became a kids show
um called wishbone which became
really um i i'll i'll say it became
beloved for people now between the ages
yeah 25
and 35 know and love this show
love it i spoke at sarah lawrence
college a couple years ago and of all
the things i've done like when that was
mentioned they went bananas oh wow and
um so
she she helped
reformat this show
and briefly it's a show about a jack
russell terrier live action who in his
dream life becomes the heroes of classic
novels
and it was kind of ingeniously
constructed so he lived in this
fictional neighborhood
um his owner joe and had a couple
friends they'd go on adventures and you
would hear his internal monologue and he
would remind him so for instance
they were trying to save a park from
developers
and that reminded him
of the odyssey and odysseus trying to
save his home from interlopers when he's
on the way
restored from penelope's under siege by
by these guys these marauders and so or
he would be in a kennel separated from a
beagle he fell in love with and that
would make him think of romeo and juliet
and so there would be twin plots you'd
go in and out oh my god it was um a job
i go back to all the time it was
storytelling boot camp oh cool any kind
of skill
whatever skill i have for telling a
story a lot of it comes from that wow
because if you think about it you wrote
on it as well yeah i was a writer and a
producer but i was really a writer and
each episode was a different classic
novel and it had to be boiled down to 30
minutes four kids through the eyes of a
dog yeah and i could and in retrospect
it was just
an amazing exercise for learning about
what makes a story work
great thing about writing for kids is
that you can't mark time you can't just
fill stuff in with characters jabbering
yeah lean and dynamic and christians
move forward yeah how do you pick your
subjects form obituaries where do you
find the inspiration are they just
things that you are naturally drawn to
do people write in do people most of
them have been things i do have to sort
of feel it in my gut yeah you know i
think
i'm more sure of myself to kind of trust
what sort of is giving me a warm feeling
in my belly oh of course and that's and
it's
you can tell that from the episodes i
mean it you feel genuinely engaged and
curious that that's what seems to fuel
these episodes yeah i think that
audiences can read it totally
you know you have to care about it like
one of the worst pieces i've done on
sunday morning
is on sherlock holmes and i'm sorry i'm
just not a sherlock holmes person
i'm just not into sherlock holmes i'm
also not
into outer space
strongholds in outer space are two
things that are just not interesting to
me so the two of them together would be
an absolute no sherlock holmes in in
outer space would be something you
weren't in okay because i had something
i wanted to pitch you and i will not
even
attempt it um i liked when josie and the
[ __ ] cats went into outer space because
i liked that i thought that was kind of
fun yeah i'm doing that but that was
animated
but sherlock holmes and i was i'm also
not that interested in things that are
happening underwater like i like things
i like things on land
were you into bed numbs and broomsticks
were your bed knobs and broomsticks i
can barely remember
yeah what was it about
those lives about obituaries that that
you were drawn to um i think that having
older parents
made me more interested in the past
maybe
i mean my father was born in 1929 so he
was pre-rock and roll he wasn't a baby
boomer he was a name for it's like the
lost generation i can't remember what
the name yeah i keep forgetting what
it's called
but so
to him like elvis was
he was bing crosby yeah
he loved to watch old black and white
movies
and so
that was different than my other friends
and what their parents liked it felt
like i had a connection
to something farther back yeah my father
had a great sense of the romance of life
he loved obituaries his obituaries are
about someone's life not their death
yeah i mean if they're done right
i also
like to be
generous with the past you know i liked
doing billy carter and being generous to
him the family seemed very touched by
they were your respect for for his
legacy in his life yeah i mean obviously
no one is perfect he wasn't perfect
he became this caricature of a redneck
but
he was a guy
in a tiny town in georgia
whose older brother decides to run for
president it's not billy's choice right
the even in 1976 there was a lot of
media to descend on that town yeah the
family business which he expected to run
has to be put into a blind trust because
the carters were scrupulous that way
and he has six kids and so
his decision his
understandably is to perfect to become
professionally billy carter to make his
money
being
the brother of the yeah
yeah a caricature almost yeah and
that's what had survived i mean that you
know
the beer
yeah that's what i i remember just i had
a teacher at jesuit school father barry
who looked like homer simpson he looked
like a red-faced homer simpson and he
used to talk like this and he would
reduce these figures in history to a
couple bullet points you know like pope
innocent iii he was a bad but whatever
it was and um so i remember sometimes i
think of history in those terms like uh
a few things about you know
cromwell or whoever it is that would be
like the ma or the magna carta i knew a
few bullet points about these people and
and
billy
carter is an example of that i knew he
was kind of buffoonish and he had a beer
and there was some and you maybe if you
really like advanced you vaguely
remember that there was some scandal
with libya and you got it right that's
right
and and i'm not saying that everyone
should walk around having like an
encyclopedic knowledge of of billy
carter or i just for me it's it's a fun
fulfilling thing to do
to fill that out and find out who he was
i think like the same smugness that goes
along with a lot of cancel culture is
related to the smugness of kind of
looking at the past as just being
universally backward right yes
dismissing and disqualifying people from
writing them off yes
so easy to do yeah yeah do you think
about that how you might be remembered
what your obituary might be like you're
mo [ __ ] i think at different points
i've have and
now what i'd like to do what gives me
what makes me happy
is if i can make
people interested in things
that i'm interested in and things that
they didn't expect to be interested in
that feels like worthwhile work to me
yeah
the challenging part it's a good
challenge is
it's fun to know a lot of random facts i
used to be as a kid big memorizer of the
encyclopedia and the almanac are you
into jeopardy
yeah yeah and and i love it but i don't
want to be like a walking game show
contestant who just knows a lot of data
points right people love that guy yeah i
mean
it's great but like but um raised a lot
of money for charity but um but but you
know it's part of of the fun and going
back kind of to wishbone is learning how
to take
these things and build them into stories
yeah i would say your show is
such a great example of that oh well
thank you for that seriously thank you
uh emote what is your most commonly used
emoji would you say when you text
if you use it i like the angry face
because i think it's really cute with
the one uh i think yeah the yeah the red
why yeah it's really cute you mean the
the one with the squinty yeah yeah
actually angry orange red sort of like i
think it's like i just i just think it's
kind of funny yeah um if
if you could be a professional athlete
what sport would you play oh well i
would shouldn't jump i i'd be i'd be a
gymnast i would i like floor exercises
yeah yeah sure um if you could have one
snack food for the rest of your life
what would it be
oh i love the tasty cakes that sort of
undulate like the shape of them and they
have like with a like a butterscotch or
a cream topping oh like a hostess cake
well it's cheesy cake oh it's a
different brand from brains i think it
may have been acquired by hostess during
the course of this interview okay okay
um i'll chill we'll fact check that um
what's your favorite movie of all time
if you have one uh
um
i mean i always love the birds i love a
place in the sun very much oh yeah i
don't know why the place it's really
rivets me i love um are you afraid of
birds do you ever fear
no but i've been to bodega bay four or
five different times oh when they shot
it and yes oh i you know it's because
it's terri because that it's terrifying
as a child and i loved being terrified
as a child
and then you realize hitchcock's genius
that it's terrifying and hysterically
funny also yeah like the diner scene
with mrs bundy the old woman with the
beret it's been a while since i remember
and she's like birds have been around
for two and a half billion years ago i'm
telling you they attacked the school
children and there's a drunk guy going
kill all the birds of filthy creatures
and then there's a woman who kind of
looks like an older rachel dratch going
scaring the children
it's like it's an amazing ensemble of
people i worked with tippy hedren and uh
i remember she told me about
obviously years before me too movement
and all that she told me about her
experience with with hitchcock and how
hit you know she was
that this would be a good uh subject for
well i've had two different i've
profiled two different hitchcock blondes
eva marie saint and kim novak so i
haven't been
in north
north by northwest of kim novak is
vertigo um both of them
well even maurice saint took pains to
say look i'm not discounting anyone
else's stories all i can tell you is i
had a great relationship with him kim
novak said that she loved hitchcock um i
did meet tippy hedren once because a
friend took me to a birthday party at
shamballa the safari oh right
yeah where she rescues animals um so i
picture with her when i weighed like 115
pounds like i was really oh and you're
up yeah
so i weighed a little bit more than i
did in high school and and i just
remember that she when she signed her
name she put like little doodle birds
like
remarks
she went now you can say you've met
tippy hadron and the birds and oh that
was really exciting
who is your favorite muppet do you have
a favorite muppet oh i like gonzo
because i know i always associated gonzo
with jimmy durante like like i love
jimmy duran yeah yeah kind of like a you
know broken nose
yeah yeah
yeah
yes uh if you could have dinner with
three people that are alive whom you've
never met
i was the the marx brothers three of
them but you have to choose right yeah
you'll throw a zeppo in there or gummo
just to make the mix things up a little
bit i think zeppo was meant to be like
the funniest one all the brothers would
say how funny he was or um
yes i think that's right i i always
confused zeppo and gumo because one of
them essentially became their agent and
then the other one yes got went into the
garment business i think it became very
successful right i think zeppo did uh
and gummo yeah uh
and apparently harper i remember allen
uh alan um arkhan was was obsessed with
with the marx brothers uh and told me
some of these guys i really needed i
really wanted alan arkin to talk to me
about audrey hepburn because apparently
in wait until dark
he found it hard to terrorize her that's
how lovable audrey hepburn oh i can't
wait to hear that episode it was on the
first season right yeah yeah oh and my
mother was obsessed with audrey hepburn
what oh interesting oh i'd love to hear
that uh watch audrey hepburn on
tonight's show it's really odd
because
johnny and i'm not
i'm i'm not going back in the past and
picking on them because johnny carson's
amazing but you do realize how times
have changed like any time a woman who's
reasonably attractive at least
reasonably attractive is on
and i think this makes sense yeah in its
own way
is that's how johnny relates it's always
like one of the first questions is
usually you know about her would you
ever thought of dating me or like
yeah you know what do you think of a
like and i were talking earlier about
pickup lines that you know yeah so it's
interesting and that's sort of that
that's the kind of becomes the the
connection yes
it is but when andre hepburn comes on
she's so kind of otherworldly and johnny
is sort of stammering he doesn't have
his footing oh he's kind of disarmed by
her yeah
and she's it's weird to see her on a tv
show because she exists on this other
plane yeah it's very strange i know what
you mean yeah interesting and this was
in this then the 70s 70s i think she did
this movie with sean connery like some
robin hood type movie and
and after she her career was basically
14 years long but she did a couple of
things afterwards and
and yeah and they're trying to johnny
and ed are literally trying to figure
out what the word is that would describe
her and they're like sexy isn't quite
right
and then she's like rolling with it
it's it's just it's it's weird it was
just so classy and kind of yeah
yeah evolved almost that they didn't
know how to that's i gotta see that um
if you could have one superpower what
would it be
oh um
well i i mean i really would love to
keep my flexibility i've been losing
i've been extremely flexible all my life
um but um
uh
that's a good one
yeah yeah um
if you could be one age for the rest of
your life physically what would you pick
what a great question i'm gonna say
fifty fifty was down fifty one now fifty
it was very good for me yeah so i liked
fifty yeah oh that's good to know okay
um hair looks great yeah
yeah
if you could be um
reincarnated uh as a non-human animal
what would you pick
well a beaver can hold its breath for 45
minutes oh wow yeah um
um
but they're constantly working
they're constantly working and that's
true um
uh
i had a tree in my front yard in
massachusetts this little birch tree i
mean it wasn't
the circumference wasn't that impressive
but it was
it one day just was down it was like and
i thought oh my god that
the wind was there a storm i didn't and
i examined it and there were these
nod these two tooth marks on it and a
[ __ ] beaver i couldn't believe that
a little animal could could do this kind
of damage
i'm gonna go with a beaver yeah okay i
just told you uh would you rather be
called unattractive or unfunny
boy it's interesting how
unfunny just cut so hard
i think probably i'd rather be called
but boy but unattractive also carries
personal connotations as well like an
unattractive person that's true um
so yeah i suppose i'd rather be called
on funny because i guess you i would
just say well i'm not
i don't agree with them yeah yeah um
which golden girl do you most identify
with there's dorothy blanche i probably
don't have to tell you dorothy blanche
rose or sophia
well i i mean i liked
um
uh
sofia
the most i also just think estelle getty
like yeah i think she just had such a
great life like she'd been in the
yiddish theater and then she wrote
emily and then harvey fierstein put her
in in the la production torch song
trilogy as his mother and that's when
the producers found her really had this
full rich life
and then this amazing thing happened to
her
when she was already
kind of like
you know what i mean it's so great like
when that happens to people who have
developed this core and made
solid choices yes and then now they're
doing something purely for the joy of it
yeah and so i think like she probably
had a great life wow oh that should be
an interesting subject yeah um
dogs or cats do you prefer
um i i've had
i managed to train
a couple of the cats that i've had i
don't have a cat now but i have two cats
to be canine like so affectionate cats
oh wow so yeah so a canine like cat oh
that's great that's one of that's my big
issue with cats is that yeah they're not
affectionate is most short for moses for
maurice maurice yeah yeah did your
parents call you maurice when you were
kidding yeah and they still do and i
like that they do in fact i don't
i have a couple of old friends that have
started calling me moe and i don't like
that i wish that they would just call me
maurice i kind of like that i'd like to
hold on to a few people
i'd like a few people to hold on to that
yeah
maurice sendak i think maurice
well when you know it was it's a name i
was self-conscious about growing up
because it was old-fashioned kind of
old-fashioned and it seemed like
slightly femi or something so even
though it's really it's not but it made
me insecure and so then my father would
say well maurice chevalier but mauricio
valley yeah for thank heaven for little
girls is on the alps
so you can't really cling to that and
then so and so
maurice which is you know it's a creepy
song it is
objectively um but um but maurice and it
was kind of yeah
um a chocolate candy or a fruity candy
would you choose uh probably
um
fruity yeah yeah i like better chocolate
but i don't i don't want a lot of milk
chocolate yeah um and meatloaf the food
or meatloaf the singer if you could only
have one for the rest of you you hear
meat loves music or you oh i'm me love
the food yeah i think meatloaf is a
pretty good solid food and uh what would
you do you want to be buried how do you
want to be your your own roommate i was
thinking now i have thomas paine yeah
his bones are scattered all over the
world um
you don't want that
i don't want my bones to be scattered i
i'd like
i'd like my organs i think i'd like my
organs to be i would like my organs to
be useful to somebody yeah um
yeah um i don't think you need them you
don't believe in any sort of
that that kind of more
orthodox catholic version of the
afterlife where which my dad revealed to
me recently where they
i i think he might believe this that his
body will be used again
uh
a catholic's body will you know which is
why they don't they're not crazy about
cremation right um
i don't know i think it would be nice to
have a place where people can go and
obviously i can be in earned which
happens if you're cremated
you know but um but you're rolling your
eyes well i just don't want to be like
in a bank like like like like in the the
lobby of your building with all the mail
things right i don't want people to find
me that way it would be nice if
i don't need like a huge like a
mausoleum right but a quiet little
quiet little thing yeah that would be
nice um and uh
well okay well i it's funny is that did
just do you think about that kind of
thing often do you think about your own
death and mortality and
sure i mean i think um
i think of the things i certainly think
of the things i'd like to do and that
there is a little bit of a ticking clock
yeah you know i mean i i i i i
i can't wait forever
to have kids i don't think it would work
you want to one day maybe i think
i think it would be
look maybe just maybe the maybe it will
just occur to me that it's too late at
one point and then just move on well
maybe but
older parents so it's unique yeah yeah
and so um
what i haven't what i haven't considered
you know you start to when you when when
you have friends and family members that
have bad health
um i haven't considered until now that i
could be somebody with a chronic illness
or something like that i mean i've had
really good health i'm in good health so
i always i'm like
but you know you don't know yeah so but
i i i i guess i don't spend time
dwelling on it but um
i mean i don't know i'm torn because
there is a lot i want to do so i say
like oh we won't be remembered but on
some level maybe that's spurring me to
want to do more do more things that i
definitely like doing right and not be
so
not do it for any sort of notoriety or
it's the thing that you think is
expected of you well what i've tried to
get out of which i think was a hard
thing for me is do this visit will lead
to that yeah and that's
i don't
i think that's a weird fearful delay
tactic yeah well if you do this if you
take that job for the next year it could
lead to this right i mean sometimes that
works sometimes it does especially if
you need to learn something sure but if
it's just because oh and then they'll
see me in this and then they'll pick me
for that right what are you doing true i
used to be a beholden to that kind of
yeah uh mindset um well i i i'm so
grateful to your uh to your podcast
because it's something that i
i and i encourage everyone to listen to
it um and it strikes me that you
really love doing it that that there's a
joy yeah they're they're it's they're
they're they're yes there absolutely is
there's a there's a joy to it and
there's a there's a great joy to
thinking there's a great joy to people
becoming interested in something
that
you're interested in yeah and and that
maybe if you'd walked into a pitch
somebody would have said i'm not sure
about that right yeah but but when you
follow through and it feels it feels
great well i'm i'm grateful to you for
that and and for doing this for so long
too i'm sorry that's really fun
good likewise uh well
more to come thanks man thank you
[Music]
so
so that hap that happened that's your
[ __ ] yeah can i hear it again so that
happened
uh it's a little bit that's not great he
has a he has a slight no it's more like
this nobody sounds wait wait how's this
it's more like this so that happened so
yeah it's a little bit like
it's a little bit like um
you know what it is it's it's great he
has a great voice he does it is an ex
it's an exaggerated
he's like a grown-up precocious kid yes
it's sort of know those kids who are
like yes hello hello mrs long were like
overly polite who were like really
impressive yeah it pleased to meet
aren't you thinking a lot in particular
that i that i don't want to say his name
yes he was sort of like so it's
yeah that's that's good closer to this
and it's and when he gets excited he
does have this child like
uh energy just he's a precocious nerdy
kid grown up yeah that's well said yeah
that's a very good i hope he's not
insulted by that i shouldn't i think
it's in the best way i mean that as a i
agree with that as a comment he's so
cool can you do that if somebody else uh
makes a claim about somebody can you say
instead of saying he shouldn't be
insulted no instead of saying i i mean
that in the best way can you say i agree
with that in the best way
ah i've never heard that but i get what
you're saying i agree with that that is
a very good assessment uh he's a very
interesting
human being i think and
and i think what makes him i love
talking about what makes him so
interesting is how interested he is in
other people yes
he's so
he's so interested in other people it
makes him so interesting he's genuinely
interested it's not that kind of like i
don't know i find that with certain
actors actresses that kind of like [ __ ]
oh really like over listening and yeah
it's fit it's like phony curiosity and
she's really real respect for the past
yeah i love that i like what he said
about um he finds it sort of smug when
people
dismiss the past yes yeah yeah you know
that's arrogant that that they're in our
council culture yeah but people kind of
well that's not important anymore yeah
and it's i find i i
really dislike that too because there's
something about i know that especially
in our country youth
is um often
so promoted
and so unfairly promoted
and well to the point where everything
else falls by the wayside almost yeah to
the point where
elderly people don't get the respect
that they deserve yeah um whereas in a
country like japan let's say the elderly
are treated
much much differently yeah they are here
they're just respected more i yeah i
wonder if that's why he really
took to japan yeah maybe or maybe maybe
he picked that up in japan i i was
wondering that
if that's what the show does it's given
me a whole like a newfound appreciation
for these people that yeah i've heard
about audrey hepburn i've seen a few of
her movies um i know that our own mother
like fetishized you know i've never seen
an audrey hepburn movie get out of here
really no roman holiday never saw it
breakfast at tiffany's never saw it oh
i'm not i'm with him
but i'm not i'm i'm ashamed oh you've
never seen like any
like scenes
i've seen maybe like a three second clip
of her i know what she looks like i'm
very well aware right she looks i mean
she's got an icon i mean that's she does
audrey hepburn only
worked as a professional actress for
like 14 years i think
and then i think she said yeah yeah and
so and then she became well his and his
obituary about audrey hepburn uh taught
me so much about her about how she you
know you know she lived during the nazi
occupation of the netherlands well we
should i should listen to that uh that
podcast you should and it explains why
she stopped acting i should listen to
that podcast i guess yes it's not so
interesting to hear somebody raise your
hand for you
no offense about this podcast no i know
um check it out but i'm surprised that
she was even featured and
because she's so famous i thought it i
thought it dealt more with people who
it's not like
not necessarily there are a few others
that were like thomas payne is not
obscure i mean he's coming
the uh the one about the siamese twins
seemed interesting
it it really is i'm not i wasn't just
teaming no talk too much about it okay
okay i'm just saying in a very super
emotional level i've always been
interested in um siamese twins yeah and
now i think well they talk about this in
the podcast but they it's an operation
that they can that they would have been
separated now if they had the money to
do so but it's a very complicated it's
complicated but the one the way they
were conjoined um
it wasn't as risky to separate them i
don't think it's considered there's like
a six-inch it's cartilage yeah and and
they didn't sh i don't think they shared
it's crazy imagine can you imagine being
stuck with me
well i mean really stuck with me this is
nothing i know i know i know this is
nothing can you imagine i heard that
episode i i felt so grateful for my for
not being stopping me
to anybody
if i was gonna be stuck with somebody
i'd wanna be stuck with you me too yeah
but i wouldn't want to be stuck with you
both have to not want to be stuck with
each other but please talk with each
other
um
yeah but i would not want it that would
be i wouldn't want to be stuck with you
either no i know
i'm not it's not an insult to you i
wouldn't want to be stuck with anybody
but
but stuck i know i know because think
about it because and that's what i'm
thinking about it's awful
i'm thinking about bathroom stuff of
course
bathroom stuff bedroom stuff bedrooms
what would you rather uh what's worth
but if you're just like all right let's
say you can suffer bedrooms let's say
you could take like a pill that just
knocks you out and you know the person's
gonna be out but you can only take it
once a day for something for like 10
minutes i would take it for potential
bedroom stuff for 10 minutes let's say
you could say it lasts 20 minutes let's
just say bedroom or bathroom what do you
what no no no that's going to eliminate
life
how about this even better let's say it
lasts for a half hour what would you do
with your time
while
the pill knocks the other person out for
30 minutes bedroom stuff
wouldn't you try to squeeze in both
you mean bathroom stuff too yeah i think
i might like doing bathroom stuff to
attach to you because it'd be funny to
make you
make you experience that i'd get used to
it it would get old like it would it
would stop being funny wouldn't that
isn't what that's that's
that's when you'd be like that's when
you go to your doctor's what are the
risks well you know what we'd have to do
we'd have to get on the same schedule
yeah we'd think we'd have to have women
and sync up their periods exactly we'd
have to is that an old wives tale i
don't know we'd have to sync up our poo
our poos
boot schedule our poo schedule
i feel i don't know how you do that that
they
you go into that state of like i don't
you shut down
the way he described it was like a
meditative you would have to you would
have to just
what if you can't
i think you would i think you would have
you would
if you were like you get like rascally
and like while like bedroom stuff was
going on you're just like
see you're thinking of the first like
month of this existence i don't think i
could do it i don't think you would
you'd get used to it especially if this
is
they know that's true you're right
you're right and they take turns
like they were so much worse yeah yeah
because it's like how do you ask
a a lover
to do that and especially sisters that's
right that might make it easier so chang
as you now know because you've heard it
they were married to two sisters and you
know the most fascinating part one of
the most uh interesting parts of that
that story is that they were slave
owners did we talk about that no and
they were very like pro confederacy they
were in fact they they put all of their
money into the confe into confederate
bonds
and that's how they lost their fortune
chang
that's how they put all
isn't that amazing i feel less sorry for
them now i know i know and and
especially knowing what it was like to
be oppressed not only as
asians they were from thailand siam at
the time
um in in north carolina
again you should we should listen listen
uh okay
yes it's very morocco of me yeah no
morocco would have much better success
yes and he would have been more audience
and what they wanted what they want to
hear he'd be more sure of the
information yeah
speaking of morocco
the show is about is sorry um
i feel like
you two would make a a good couple ah i
swear to you well you don't have to
think that jose and mo rock are making a
couple
i do i was thinking that you're both i
was thinking that i could do that you're
both thin
and
and curious about people you'd be great
and you like history
but i would tolerate it i would i i you
like murray's crisis i sure do
by the way that was a pretty gay moment
in my life where i i lit up when he when
mo mentioned maurice crisis which for
those of you who
don't know is a um
is a piano bar in the heart of uh
in
the greenwich village in like the
uh in the gay section of greenwich
village is it is it offensive to call it
a gay section now uh i don't know what's
offensive if you're asking the wrong
person i know it is a very gay section
it is yeah and it's uh a place
that i love i love it too yeah we've got
a lot of fun there it's not bad to say
for us because we love it
so we're saying it in a good way that's
true i'm just trying to describe the
area um it is a piano bar
and they play
show tunes mostly show tunes i think
most
exclusively yeah that's true and it's
everyone is down there having a great
time singing along to these show tunes
yeah and it's like you know when you see
movies of like that take place in the
17th or 1800s and and there's the scene
before they go to battle where they're
like all in the bar
singing around the piano and
making merry yeah it's a it's a place of
merriment we went there a couple of
months ago maybe everyone's drinking ale
and they have mutton legs and we had the
best time we went
six months ago and
uh i hadn't been there in a while yeah
we went with maggie my girlfriend and
her friend catelyn and
um and i didn't know her friend very
well at all oh yeah and at one point she
like i caught her looking over at me
like belting out a show tuned
and she
was seemed very confused you were like
there are giants in the sky
yeah she was very i am the very model of
a major general i saw her questioning my
sexuality
but you know what it was their first
time meeting you uh one of maggie was
like this is my boyfriend and you were
like and she was like i'm like one day
another day another destiny
that's so funny yeah justin i both love
musical theater but i i getting back
together and the blood of angry man yeah
we were so into it that night we were
like
and every night at marie's crisis i
can't recommend this place don't go
there unless you're into musical theater
yeah if you're at all intolerant of
you know that lifestyle stay far away
uh it is just the best it's the best uh
but you and morocco
morocco makes me sort of sad that you're
not a homosexual i know he'd be great to
travel with he'd be great he'd be great
he's so intelligent he seems kind yeah
um
he's not intimidatingly handsome like if
i were with a guy who was like
like a real like like a tom
i'd be like
i feel very inadequate yeah you'd feel
like you'd feel like his little
assistant wouldn't be weird to be with
uh date tom brady sex uh lover who's
like so much better looking much better
looking it would be weird it's weird
enough to do i it's weird enough to date
i know women who are right now better
looking than you yes and we've both done
that of course i'm doing it right
exclusively that means
um he he sounds he also sounds another
reason you guys make a good couple is
because he sounds like he had a somewhat
similar upbringing
um yeah
yeah ultra boy ultra blood jesus jesuit
all boys high school
uh restrictive parents yeah who did he
let him watch certain no your stomach
yeah really parents wouldn't want let
them watch certain tv shows yeah our
parents wouldn't let us watch certain tv
shows um i love married with children
remember they hated oh yeah what did she
call it my mom was always like filthy
filthy yeah that's filthy and it's so
funny you watch that now and it seems so
tame compared to the things that are out
there he talked about liking that
restrictive childhood though and i i
really feel him on that yeah because
there's something about not being
allowed to do something it makes that
like it makes more precious he said he
used the word tantalizing it makes it
tantalizing it makes it tantalized
when you finally do get it yeah remember
like yes the excitement oh my god yeah
not to like out myself his little
pervert but i was a boy so all boys are
perfect sorry that's something
like the second i got my hands on a
playboy magazine oh my god do you
remember it was like the holy grail
remember that feeling that the heavens
would open oh my god angelic voices
would play and now it's like
or if you don't have restricted parents
it's like all right no big deal i know
with the internet i don't know
imagine growing up holy [ __ ] all those
sights at your fingertips it's be too
much
too much i wonder if the sex lives of
these of this next generation is going
to be all out of work i bet it's i bet
they're going to be rewarded it's going
to be right and the things that they're
going to expect and how how about the
way
men of the next generation will see
women those that have been so exposed
overexposed to like
any kind of what that porn and
holy [ __ ] i feel old um how about what
were you going to say remember this
feeling getting the uh
when sports illustrate because we had a
subscription to sports illustrated
issues yeah no the
nfl preview issue the larry bird
and danny the march madness
preview
yeah like i'll never i mean i i have a
pretty bad memory but um i can still i
can like i know have such like finite
details of some of those covers yeah
from back in the day kathy i alright so
i guess you weren't a homosexual no it's
like you would rock it won't work out
no but like
i'd still be great to be his buddy
yeah he could still be his friend but he
he seems more like a good life partner
because he seemed like you said he seems
like a good person to travel with
and to meet new people yeah it's hard to
do that with a buddy if i think of her
or yeah you know he seems like like a
good person to be in a romantic
relationship right yeah
i bet i think if i were going to marry a
man it would be doug sills
[Laughter]
doug would be a great husband he would
be a good yeah not just because he has a
great house we already act like a
married couple yeah you do you know he's
like
he's mad for being messy yeah i'd like
him as a
brother-in-law yeah is being protective
if he's based yes he'd be the man he'd
be like yeah he'd be the man but also in
some ways he'd be more of a um
and he'd be like the taskmaster a little
bit and
you know i'd be there like he'd like
roll his eyes at me because i didn't
clean up enough i don't know who does
that role now i sound like you're
excited about the potential of this
relationship
you guys talked about um the idea of
that some people are
always old like angela lansbury yeah
well from brimley you know who else is
always old um neil young is always old
yes ironically yes yes
do you remember when we saw uh do you
remember that that documentary um that
jacob dillon did echo in the cave in the
canyon yeah why are you laughing because
you have recommended it
i know it's been months it's been a
while but uh do you remember having that
revelation when we were watching that
because there's old footage of neil
young like when he was on uh the jack uh
not jack benny the johnny not johnny
carson
the girl the beatles uh
sullivan yeah that was terrible it
wasn't terrible i it it made me realize
whoever you were talking about it was so
effective
the uh how did you now it's getting
worse
he was kind of the beatles
is that like that yeah how does his
mouth go how did harry's mouth go didn't
he have a
oh [ __ ] don't look it up don't look no
no no no no i want to hear him don't
don't really no
because
who cares all right but
well we can also test our little you
know the record here christian i got a
new little piece of equipment so we can
play phone calls more effectively phone
calls phone calls if you've been
listening to the check-in episodes
you will know that they're not the
clearest okay who was i looking at but
neil young was oh yeah
he was almost older as a young man than
he is now as an old man you know yes yes
yes he was like he was like an old
teenager an old 22 year old i knew some
teenagers like that in high school some
kids in high school who who seem like
old men i bet wilford brimley was like
that yeah will it willie brimley
wilfy uh
okay let's see
while you look that up um i also thought
it was funny the people together may i
point out that they'll be on our show as
i told our audience for the next two
years
all right
hollywood's exciting missy hollywood
hollywood
once again hollywood hollywood
ah they're so cool
is it me this is gonna be controversial
not controversial who cares at this
point but um
uh what you people should care i i was
about to say something that stepped on
what we said about mo earlier uh is does
ed sullivan not seem like the most
entertaining human being to you to be
honest with you i only know him from
ladies and gentlemen the beatles so i
don't really know anything about him
that that's a subject that moe should do
for his obituaries but what if he turned
out not to be that remarkable that's
true i'm sure there's a reason why he
was such a he was um he was the biggest
entertainer i never thought wait a
minute was he not a big entertainer i i
don't know you're asking the wrong
person i don't know much about did he
just kind of announce people you know i
i think i thought that way about dick
clark
too yeah until um
because and ryan seacrest and i was
associated with dick clark because
uh they do similar things and ryan
secrets kind of took over yeah
but
i saw ryan seacrest i thought he was
kind of like anyone could do this job
kind of guy
until i saw a live taping oh american
idol right so he's amazing impressed
yeah in person because he keeps the ball
in the air it's so difficult to do it
yeah i think let's read
the letter okay here we go mom's also
pretty tall in terms of being like uh a
couple lover yeah not a lover not the
active lovemaker i don't know what that
how that would affect i don't want to
think too much about it because i don't
know what the mechanics would be
this is also like
who knows if he'd want to date you oh
it's very presumptuous yeah very
presumptive i think we get along pretty
good
that's very presumptuous having said
that i bet he would no no i don't know
what his type is
i have a feeling it's someone like you
why
it would seem weird if he was into a guy
like brian bosworth or something
wouldn't it wouldn't that seem weird
you're probably seeing those couples
kind of intellectual
yeah
don't but gay couples tend to yeah yeah
go for similar they do i guess from what
i've seen i've seen a lot of similar and
from ones i know oh yeah they tend to
you know birds of a feather kind of
thing yes male bird's pathetic yeah
uh yeah but not females not all so much
i i no no it's different i think i know
listen we should probably we're not
authorities
on this
but i've seen that often especially in
the area of new york that we live we
live in an area called chelsea
and um
there is a type of in fact
uh many
gay men i don't know if i can say this
they call those people who live there
chelsea boys and
that would suggest a certain physical
type which is
muscular muscular yeah um
[Music]
often leather
bound
um
but but i see though those type physical
leather clad i don't think that person
is leather that's true bound they
couldn't move right leather bound is
like a book or that gina gershon movie
yeah
um
yeah you're right wow i'm making a lot
of uh grammatic anyway my point is my
really wonderful point is i've seen
a lot of uh leather clad
uh
here suit men with one another
oh good have you yeah no i know i like
hairs i
i think gay men tend to date
men of their type i do too i know it
doesn't happen all the time and of
course not yeah but from what i from my
like i just saw an anecdotal experience
yeah for example i just saw uh pete
booty chitcha's is that how you say it
buddha judge buddha jade but do i add an
extra booty
[ __ ]
his husband is a pete buddha judge type
yes yes if there were a pete pudic uh
biopic
his real husband we're an actor he
should get cast yeah absolutely what's
his name it's a funny name it's like
jason jason yeah um yeah jason
apparently has two brothers who are uh
very um kind of conservative traditional
interesting uh and and frown on that
lifestyle funny movie great movie
man and they look very different from
jason it's a funny physical
juxtaposition anyway um
let's read a letter
this is a letter from stephanie
oh i gotta say her name last night
because it's it's the second part let's
see if you can guess her last name okay
it is the second name of one of the most
fun
actor names to say
actor names yes or actress
think of an actress suzie kurtz there
you go you got it kurtz yeah
pretty good good guess
this is entitled uh
greetings from colorado hello to justin
poo dollar
uh in this is in parentheses ex uh
question mark exclamation point please
explain poo dollar yeah uh when i was 15
years old justin
was in college and he told me a story
wait why are you blaming me i'm not
blaming you i'm telling you how this
name came to be okay uh i was 15 and
justin was 18 in college and he met
someone whose nickname in
life i guess was feces josh oh yeah and
feces josh who just went to college with
um used to play
feces games oh right feces josh games
called hide the duke was one right
a game called poo dollar was why i i
should clarify i wasn't very good
friends with this guy fine fine so
justin told me about this game called
poo dollar where um you take a bill a
dollar bill people probably know this
game fine but in case they don't yeah 20
dollar bill you rub poop on one side of
it and then you put it it is so gross
you put the bill poo side down on the
sidewalk or something you scurry around
and you hide in a bush and you wait for
someone to walk down the street and
think oh my gosh my
lucky day yeah someone i got a free bill
awful and then they pick up a poo dollar
you have to have a lot of shot in front
when i was 15 years old i thought that
was really funny i've never done it or
seen it done but i thought it was funny
so i named my instagram name uh-huh poo
dollar yeah yeah
uh you've found it funny for that line
i've always found it funny yeah it's you
know i i find it much less funny now but
it's but it's been associated with other
accounts i've had in the past right that
was good yeah
have you ever found a real poo dollar no
uh i saw one once i didn't touch it i
didn't go for it but i saw one in
milwaukee wisconsin once are you sure it
was a real poodle yeah it was clearly it
had been clearly
pooed upon it was like if i saw one
would be like it would be like meeting
it would be like meeting a celebrity or
something
i feel like meeting a real poo dollar
huh no and uh there are a few times i've
seen um
pooh on this pool on the street many
times i've seen people on the street
i've seen dollars on the streets
and you know i i never pick it up well
or you examine no very careful no no no
never pick it up never pick up a dollar
on the street yeah but i mean you know
it's very likely a poo dollar it's not
very likely it's possible that it's a
pudding i've never found a non poo
dollar i've never picked up a dollar on
you haven't no for fear that's a poo
dollar oh i have i have that's how cheap
i am that's that's where we're different
yeah back to stephanie's letter i just
heard the uh lis episode where you both
mentioned you are sick oh yeah
i hope for a speedy recovery thank you
stephanie and appreciate you released a
quickie episode anyway
uh i actually think you should do this
every other week
we might this is fun to do spread out
your can deps and alternate ones where
you just call people who won't pick up
the phone smiley face for the record so
glad you didn't edit that out because it
makes our shared experience more real
this is the one reason i prefer your
podcast over many of the other songs
it's nice it's not that you seem less
produced but you seem more honest that's
nice um i like that you answered we
talked about pooh a lot more than yeah
that's the best part
uh i like that you answered the random
actor studio questions too it felt like
a modern day edition of teen beast
also justin some of us know who tony
basil is
she has a lot of sm i'm not
reading all the smiley face but the
old-fashioned smiley emoji you know the
colon and the
parenthetical i identified with your
last email or the woman who moved in
with her parents i'm a single ah here we
go i'm a single 40 something and
recently relocated from chicago she
she does emojis like 40 something and
recently relocated from chicago to
denver so i could be near my elderly
folks that's nice they are both in good
health but my mom is 80 and it felt like
it was time to be close same i moved
into their house temporarily she puts in
caps to transition jobs and to be able
to help but their denver suburb and
calling it a suburb is generous isn't
quite the epicenter of entertainment on
a good day so i guess i am saying thank
god for podcasts especially yours you
two are doing a great job definitely
keep the laughs coming btw who is the
dum-dum who said don't crack jokes right
now
that said don't feel like you have to
always put on a show we get it you need
time off too that said very grateful for
all you do i know it's not like you are
saving lives but you are saving sanity
okay sorry long enough email [ __ ] well
what else do you have to do thanks guys
uh thanks that is very nice i know i
feel like we don't
um first of all i don't think we feel
like we have to put on a show number one
but number two even when we do do it it
doesn't feel like we're putting on a
show which is nice yeah which makes it
easy to do yes it's kind of fun just to
hang out yeah if it felt like we were
okay and action
you know sullivan
yes ladies and gentlemen the beatles
like not to dwell on our guests today's
podcast but that's what i love about it
is that you it humanizes the person so
it's not just like i would only know ed
sullivan like that i'm through but i'm
sure there are a lot of entertainers
that i would only know that way i'm
trying to you know and his podcast
really like humanizes them do you know
who's a good interviewer dick cavett ah
the best so good the best i know if
you're looking for something to do um as
many of you are uh
during this quarantine
check out on youtube
dick cavett's interviews from back in
the day just just watch the whole thing
dick cavitt interviewing marlon brando
john lennon oh the john lennon the woody
allen one is great um
i i recently saw the jimi hendrix one
just really
fascinating
really cool and you see a whole side of
uh some of these entertainers
that you you may never have seen that
was good because quarantine advice yeah
okay
were you being sarcastic no
you're uh pulling on your mustache hairs
are you just gonna grow that the whole
time the beer uh my original plan was to
not shave until
this whole mess is over
but now i'm realizing every day more and
more that this mess is gonna be a mess
for probably a long time your face
doesn't might be a mess yeah so
it might get pretty gnarly so i don't
think i will uh so i don't have that
kind of stick to it well well this is a
fun thing for you guys to um get excited
about
for our this week's check-in episode we
can check in with your facial hair and
see where
yeah people are going to be really
excited about that that'll help the
hours you thought i was being sarcastic
just i was pulling on my mustache uh no
it was like a nice thing you said i
don't know and and i'm going to be nice
no i know i know but it didn't feel like
the most profound advice that i gave i
just was profound i said it was advice
good quarantine advice yeah okay all
right what would you recommend for
quarantine um i just started re-watching
for maybe the
fourth or fifth time in my life
the wonder years oh from the very
beginning good
god it's hard to get through an episode
of that show without crying um it's my
it's been my experience since i've been
watching them with you that i've been
unable to
yeah especially now there's something
about
i mean not only having a mild case of
the of the damn thing but also just
knowing how much people are suffering
out there and there's something like
emotional in the air i feel like yes so
that show destroys me now i think it's
the best thing that's ever been on tv
i've always thought you don't both have
to think wondering is the best thing
i've ever been through i mean i agree
yeah i think there are obviously like
comedies that i cherish so much but but
just
as a slice-of-life show
it's for my money it can't be wonder
years yeah i mean
what a cast everyone go watch the wonder
years it'll make you feel
good you'll cry in a good way um
let's wrap it up okay okay well uh
thanks to um
yeah so grateful to him and uh check out
as i've said 17 times in this podcast
check out his podcast my obituaries and
his book um
there's uh maybe a fun way to pass the
quarantine time and we're so grateful
for all of you for listening and writing
in um there's so many great emails we've
gotten i wish we had time to read them
all on the air but um we love getting
them and if you'd like to write in
and um tell us how you're making the
most of your quarantine or really
anything else if you want to ask us
questions anything you want really our
email is life is short at wondery.com
and if you are listening to this on your
way or from any sort of uh healthcare uh
work um and whatever you're doing uh
that you're out there continuing to work
so that
this time uh isn't as abnormal as it
could be and is is um
much healthier for for many of us than
it could be uh we thank you so much from
the bottom of our hearts and uh for the
rest of you please stay safe and stay
happy and maybe we'll check in on you in
a few days yes all right life could be a
dream
life could be a dream
you've been listening to life is short
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is produced by christian long
and monaco senior producer is michelle
miesh lans audio engineer is sergio
enriquez
executive producers are producers
are because it's marshall it says
marshall louie and ernan lopez
[Music]
fresh crabby
from your all
once a month as a perk oh you have like
a stone crab claw you know how they like
fall out they they can be they can
regenerate yeah then it grows again
okay that's a good question would you
rather have no hand
no only one hand and not on the other
arm
or a stone crab claw
that can
that you can eat
you eat your own hand every month and it
regenerates
uh well i
as long as it doesn't smell like crab
crabby all the time it would it would
have to then i would pick the no but
you're thinking about a dead crab smell
not like a living a living crab probably
wouldn't smell that bad yes it does i've
how do you know
no um ah that's a good question i guess
you'd have to keep it wet
i wouldn't have to
no no you wouldn't have to do that well
if it smells fishy that's my that's my
uh thing i think you're most fishy all
the time i think no no cloth it's gonna
smell a little fishy it's a crab claw
then i don't want a crack though but
think about the things you can do with
it you can it's functional or anything
else with my other hand with my right
hand and just have no hand yeah
just because of a little fish smell not
just that also
the fact that it you could hurt people
you hurt yourself who would you hurt
someone you're intimate with you keep
that out of the intimate stuff
what if you inadvertently include it
what do you mean inadvertently you know
what you're doing with your hand just
keep your hand off to the side it would
be tempting to use both hands though but
okay then if you don't have a hand you
can't use anything
fine but at least you don't have the
option of hurting somebody you're going
to be so like worked up and like not be
able to control your health
i don't know what crap
is like
it doesn't change your brain at all you
just have a crab claw it's the same you
i might take no
hand no crap because this smell thing
really worries me i think you're
confusing a dead crap smell like a
beachy smell like dead
but those are those are little
crustaceans that wash up on the crab no
but yeah if it's dry it's going to smell
crabby you don't have to like keep it
moist yeah i don't want to keep my voice
done
that sounds awful well some crabs are
land just like keep it like no no no
you're thinking of a watercraft there
are land crabs that don't have to do
that like hermit crabs
hermit crabs stink
how do you know probably no you're
making that up hermit crabs don't stink
i've had hermit crabs
you